a former president of honduras juan
orlando hernandez is being held on drugs
charges three weeks after leaving office
he's wanted by the united states for
alleged ties to narcotics trafficking he
denies any
wrongdoing dramatic scenes in this
upmarket suburb of the honduran capital
police had come to arrest the man who
only weeks ago led the country
faced with overwhelming force former
president juan orlando hernandez
surrendered himself to the officers at
his gates
cheering crowds lined the streets as he
was driven off
[Applause]
his residence was surrounded by police
the night before
after the u.s requested his extradition
in the end
those involved in drug trafficking are
going to end up facing u.s justice
the united states has demonstrated that
it's firm and uncompromising when it
comes to investigating major drug
trafficking
hernandez is being held at a military
base a supreme court judge will decide
on his extradition within two months
the u.s accuses the former leader of
being involved in drug smuggling
throughout his eight-year presidency and
even before
hernandez denied receiving bribes from
drug traffickers in a televised address
in 2019
[Applause]
i can say that it is untrue that i have
accepted money from these delinquents
in the name of the honduran people i
reiterate my complete rejection of the
accusation that a country is a drug
dealing state
after his fall from grace the former
president might soon have to make his
case again
in a u.s court